(emphatic folk singing begins)
(emphatic folk singing continues)
(emphatic folk singing ends)
- [Interviewer] All right, Lee.
Lee, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Pinon, Arizona.
- [Interviewer] And you're Navajo?
- [Leland] Dine'.
- [Interviewer] What is Dine'?
- [Leland] Dine' means, "The People,"
because Kit Carson gave us that name.
Navajo.
It's,
that means "thieves",
But so we don't, we don't,
We get offended about that
when we're called Navajos.
- [Interviewer] Oh yeah?
- Yeah.
(Interviewer and Leland
talking simultaneously)
- [Interviewer] It's a derogatory term,
for your people.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Interesting.
Tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents as a kid?
- Yeah, there was 13 of us.
My dad was always an alcoholic,
and my mom, she was a
she stay home, she was
a true mother to us.
And Dale passed away though.
My grandpa Whitewater, his name is
(Speaking foreign language).
(Speaking foreign
language) means Whitewater.
So we were raised by him
and my, my grandma too.
You know, her name was Cutfinger.
(speaking foreign language)
That's what it means.
(speaking same word)
Cutfinger.
- [Interviewer] How would you,
how would you describe your childhood?
- I would like,
I was sent, sent
to boarding school when
I was seven years old.
Seven years old.
They put me in boarding school,
because my mom couldn't afford to feed us.
And we were barely making it by, I guess.
And of course there
was 13 of us, you know,
and she sent us to boarding school.
In Tindley, Arizona.
That's where I mostly,
like I got traumatized,
mentally and physically in my mind,
to where that,
how they treated us there.
- [Interviewer] what kind
of stuff would go on?
- Of course molestation, of course,
just beat the shit out of us every day,
every morning, you know?
Sort of like a military
style kind of shit,
you know?
- [Interviewer] And this
was a foster home run
by --
- It's a Tindley boarding school.
- [Interviewer] A boarding school.
- It was run by the government.
- [Interviewer] It was run by
Caucasians or Indians or...
- No.
Oh, by white people.
- [Interviewer] All right.
- And from there I tried to move up to,
I wanted to move on, you know, so,
and then I went home,
and then my mom was there,
and she put me on placement
with
LDS.
Missionaries came around to our home
to where that they were
sort of like recruiting,
or whatever the heck you would call it.
You know, they wanted some people to,
you know, little kids school,
to go to school on placement.
placement program.
LDS.
Anyway, I went to school down in Morenci,
Pima, Fort Thomas,
and Thatcher way down
in the Southern area of the state
in Arizona.
- After I came back,
(clearing throat)
after I came back,
I decided to do something with my life.
So I just, you know, voluntarily went
into military.
Did that.
This is a sort of just like, like, like
Really,
I still have nightmares about that though.
- [Interviewer] And that was Afghanistan?
- Mmhm.
Yep.
Until I got out of there,
And my life hasn't been the same.
Then I
lost my mom, lost everybody.
even my son, you know?
So I just, and then I'm on the streets.
- [Interviewer] You been on
the streets for how long?
- Let's say for about three years now.
- [Interviewer] Your son was grown?
Yeah, he was 37 when he passed.
He passed away.
- [Interviewer] How did he die?
- I don't know.
What they say is, you know,
is it heart failure?
Heart failure.
He died in Minnesota.
He was an iron worker, very --
- [Interviewer] Iron worker?
- Mmhm.
Like those tall buildings, like, you know,
stories and stories high.
And he was a good young kid to me.
I miss him a lot.
Every day.
24 seven, I would say.
I miss him a lot.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
So alcohol is, is your,
is your, is your drug now?
- [Leland] I don't do any,
any other than alcohol.
Like drugs, meth, or you
know, marijuana or anything.
I just think it depends
(indistinct)
to keep occupied in my mind to where that,
Once it wears off, I started thinking.
I just
get emotional.
That's what I do.
But alcohol is, it helps me.
I don't know how that is, but it helps me.
- [Interviewer] What did, what did
what, what drink do you go to usually?
Vodka or --
- [Leland] Vodka.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- [Leland] Yeah. Imported.
- [Interviewer] Vodka seems popular
with the Indian population here.
- [Leland] Yeah. And then this, it's this,
you know, it makes me happy,
And then I, I actually out on the streets,
I can relate to what
people feel.
All these people are hurt
out in the streets.
They've been hurt one way
or the other, you know,
one way or another.
And we, we get along with each other.
We, we let, you know,
we back each other up, you know,
we support each other.
(Interviewer and Leland
talking simultaneously)
- [Interviewer] You have
friends on the street.
- Yeah.
- This, this, this, this, this, all it is.
Street people.
Homeless.
And we know what we want.
You know, just keep drinking the alcohol.
It's just
- [Interviewer] Native
Americans seem to have a
susceptibility to,
to alcoholism it seem, right?
It's something genetic.
Isn't it?
- It would be.
it is, it has run in my family.
- [Interviewer] Your dad.
- Yeah, my dad, my grandpa.
I mean, my grandpa used to make a run
on a horseback all the way
from pinon into Winslow,
just to get drinks, you know?
And then he used to come home
with it,
and then he used to sell.
And I remember those,
back in my younger days.
That's what they used to do.
And this is, like,
our lives ain't easy.
If you come down to,
if you come down to,
why, all the treaties been broken.
1868 treaties, you know about that?
- [Interviewer] I don't.
- You don't?
They've been broken.
And all the laws that's going on now
to where that,
to my understanding to, like, okay.
You, you, you,
the history books, science, mathematical,
and all this history.
Okay? Social studies and all that?
How come they don't,
they don't have it written down there
in the book to where
that they don't teach what they did to us.
How come they don't have that?
How come they don't teach that?
Like cutting, the long walk
to Fort Sumner that they did to us,
Kit Carson, he cut off
breasts of young ladies.
He, he killed young ladies.
How come that's not in history?
How come they don't teach that in history?
How come that's not
something in social studies?
Why is it that they don't bring that up?
Now.
All of these,
(clears throat)
minerals and environmental
issues that they have now.
I was in Standing Rock and Cannon Ball.
To perk this,
(speaking foreign language)
"Water is life."
I stand against that, I'll give you,
all your reading
and all these drillings
that are going on now,
they're just contaminating us.
We can't even have a spring water.
They're contaminating all that.
We have no right, no more.
Even our plants, even our
corn, even older cornfields.
We can't grow anything anymore,
because of the kind of contamination.
They have coal mines.
They have all this thing going on.
So there you have my story.
- [Interviewer] You feel like
the American Indian has been
shortchanged by the white man, don't you?
I mean, it's pretty clear
that it's been going on
for many years, right?
Forever.
Are you, what is the, what
is the religion that Nava--
that your, that your people follow?
Is it, it's not Christianity.
- We don't, we don't have, well,
- [Interviewer] Are you a religious man?
- Yeah. I'm tradition.
We don't believe in
Christianity or, you know,
we were put through three schools,
but they tried it and
they very influenced us
to where that they wanted
us believe in that.
But we always come back
to own traditional ways of life, you know?
- [Interviewer] So what do
you, what do you, what are the,
what do you believe?
I mean, do you believe in a God?
- We don't have a God.
I don't even know who God is.
or Jesus or Mary or all that.
We have our own,
They call it
(Speaking foreign language)
That's, that's, that's our belief.
What it means is,
"it's you who has to believe
in yourself."
Don't depend on anybody
else, but except yourself.
Your belief is this corn
pollen, white corn, yellow corn.
Then we offer that in the morning
to live another day.
Thankful for another day.
Thankful for that we live still.
- [Interviewer] Is there racism
against the Native Americans here
in New Mexico from, from
- of course.
- [Interviewer] it's bad, isn't it?
- Every border.
Just recently I heard there was another
incident that happened in Farmington.
They're real racists over there.
They just, you know,
beat up native peoples
out in the streets, you know?
in Flagstaff, Page,
Winslow, Holbrook, here
in Gallup too.
Very, very racist people.
But we try to stick up for, you know,
for each other and try
to save her, you know?
Try to save ourselves
for all, from all this.
- [Interviewer] in surviving
out on the streets here
in New Mexico,
it's gotta be very cold in the winter.
- You know what they say?
Keeps your body warm.
- [Interviewer] The alcohol?
- the whole cocaine, chemical,
and stuff like hairspray and all that.
So you won't freeze.
That's what they use.
And to keep the virus away, COVID?
- [Interviewer] Mmhm.
- 19? that's what they do.
- [Interviewer] They drink? They --
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] drink hairspray.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- Drink hairspray and --
- [Interviewer] Perfume and --
- all kinds of, you know,
- [Interviewer] Lysol, even.
- Yeah. Even, even that.
This is, it don't affect them.
You see all these guys
walking around, you know?
It don't even affect them.
And the way, it's just that, I guess,
it's because of the,
how sanitized is their body, their system.
Immune system.
- [Interviewer] Mmhm.
- Yeah. It helps them and
keeps that virus away, I guess.
- [Interviewer] What do
you see for the future
of your people?
(Leland clearing throat)
- Um.
- Hopefully we survive.
Hopefully we keep a cultural,
traditional way of life.
Hopefully these younger generations learn
what it means to be
native, to be indigenous,
to where that
they would learn our way of lifestyle,
how we brought them up, how we survived,
how we have been surviving this long.
For them to learn our
traditional songs, prayers,
the offerings that we do,
the ceremonies that we do.
I hope they catch that onto
them so they can continue
with their lives to where
that they could understand,
and then be passed on to
generation to generation.
To where that
all of the grandkids would survive.
- [Leland] I hope I see that future.
I don't know.
I can't tell you how
long I am going to live,
(Leland chuckles)
but that's, that's my prayers.
That's my songs.
That's, that's who I am.
- [Interviewer] All right, Lee.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
And good luck with the,
with whatever you do from here.
(Leland laughs)
- You're darn right.
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.